we are going to take a second though and
pause
on the phone calls and um
just pay honor to uh our friend rush
limbaugh who passed away this morning
and um uh there are very few people
in this world that create an entire
industry
elvis you know the king of rock and roll
even the beatles followed elvis you know
and
um rush created dark radio as we know it
there were a few
people doing it odds and ends here or
there but uh
the first person to do of scale uh for
sure
and uh in the process of those number of
decades
becomes an american icon and and um
a very interesting guy i got to spend a
little time with him a few times
and um obviously i was a little bit star
struck
and so whether you agreed with his
politics uh or not
uh for god's sake some of you out there
have some class today it's hard for some
of you but you ought to have a little
class
i mean if someone you completely
disagree with and you hate their message
passes away and you can't mama used to
say if you can't say nothing nice don't
say nothing at all so that's right it's
a good plan for some of you just
just shut up but um anyway
uh uh rush created an industry i mean he
and some of the guys were working with
him in the early days
took am radio and it was on life support
and brought it back to life
uh to the point that am radio stations
which were
you know prior to that almost didn't
exist in the ratings books
uh became the number one uh rated show
or
are stationed in many many cities on am
talk you know am talk radio did that wow
and uh and it was him
that uh blazed a trail and you know he
blazed the trail because there's so many
people that came along
after him that wanted to be him that's
right there's so many rush wannabes on
the air
out there um and or people that just
stepped into the same space
with their own thumbprint but some of
them not very original some of them very
original and a lot of them are friends
uh and um but uh
uh you know very here's here's what it
takes to do what he did
uh you have to have an unbelievable
intellect which he did
uh his his critical thinking skills are
unbelievable and his sense of humor
the one thing he does that so many don't
do when he's discussing stuff
is not only to make fun of himself but i
made fun of himself but he um
he's just dadgum funny uh well it was
and it's just um it's hard to think
about past tense get my
get my grammar correct here but um
his ability to deliver that and his
ability to deliver
thought things and for those of us that
are consider ourselves conservatives
uh he put words to things we were
already thinking and feeling
and uh it really wasn't like what he was
saying was new
just like me you know and you chris we
don't say anything new get out of debt
your grandmother said that
that's right you know we it's nothing
new but we've just done it with a
panache
and in a way and with enough volume that
it's touched millions of lives and
certainly he did
um and so iconic
iconic guy uh behind the scenes uh an
introvert
ah i didn't know that yeah i'm not a not
a uh
you would think as loud and uh
gregarious as he was on the air that he
would be
that way in a cocktail party and he
would just as soon not be
at a cocktail party just soon not be in
a crowd
and a lot of the guys on radio are that
way a lot of gals and stuff even on tv
they're uh you know they they don't mind
the camera they don't mind the
microphone but a crowded room is not
something they want to do
uh i'm unusual in that regard because i
am actually an extrovert but um
i'm louder in those situations than i am
here
just a little bit just a little bit but
he uh
you know you set the standard and those
are shoes that won't be filled
uh there'll be a lot of attempts in the
coming weeks for
uh all of us in the business to try to
figure out what to do now
because it leaves a gaping hole in talk
radio obviously
but no one will uh people will come
along and do their own version of
whatever they need to do i hope i hope
they don't try to just do rush again
because that'll be a mistake yeah it
would be
and because it's impossible yeah well i
can tell you i mean he's definitely an
icon
a bombastic had no fear of giving you
his opinion
uh and like you said critical thinking
skills were unmatched
uh being able to look at both sides but
also tell you what he believed
uh and his feeling and so uh prayers go
out to his family
yeah absolutely and uh we've reached out
to
the team that's around him we know all
of those and around his family and so
forth and um
all of that but uh you know it is an
interesting thing
to stand back and look at a person whose
uh life was so epic that they literally
created an industry
i mean henry ford created the assembly
line
and thereby the automotive industry
without a doubt yeah i mean there are
people say the car was invented before
henry ford yeah but
no one did it like he did it i mean
there was a he took it to scale
there were other people making cars in
their basements and
other things but you know the mass
production line
the ability to uh you know
create a factory to to make cars and
you know the ford model t's became the
thing
everybody after that was uh including
tesla's still trying to catch up
you know and um so that's what happens
and when you come in and an entire
genre an entire industry is created
around
uh a person's skill a person's ability
and so forth that that's iconic that's
iconic
and uh we've certainly uh the talk radio
portions
of the ramsey uh solutions business
uh have certainly written on the
coattails of that uh had i come out and
said i'm gonna do a
show on the radio and i'm going to take
phone calls and i'm going to teach
people how to get out of debt before
there was
before the road had been paved by
somebody like rush i would have been
laughed out of the building i was
already left out of the building several
times anyway but i would have been
really laughed out of the building
and um yeah mammoth mammoth impact
and um and really uh uh
quality quality guy again
i didn't agree with everything you said
but i don't agree with anything anybody
says i don't agree with everything hogan
says
so i don't know why you have to go there
but
i expect it i respect it yeah but i mean
you know we don't know what you if you
if you have
critical thinking skills you don't agree
with any there's no one you agree with
100
no you're right you're absolutely right
i don't even agree with jesus 100
that means that means i'm wrong and i
got to turn i got to learn something
right
but uh uh so you got to learn and you
know that
but but you know the if you can't
respect
uh the accomplishments the impact
and the quality of that then you're
missing something yeah
whether you agreed with him or not or
whether you agree with his politics or
not well i can tell you this on behalf
of the family
um i would encourage you if your life
was impacted by rush
uh in any way write a letter uh send it
to him
uh his family it would blow them away to
be able to read those stories and
remember
this man in their life amen yeah
well rest in peace my friend rest in
peace